they asked him first about the
disruption which is likely when the new
trade arrangements with the eu come into
force
on thursday night one of the things that
uh is great about this free trade deal
as you say is that we don't have tariffs
we don't have quotas
we've got a good relationship with our
friends in europe but it's also the case
that brexit means
as well as new opportunities some
specific challenges
because outside the single market and
outside the customs union
there are new customs procedures that
companies that are exporting into europe
need to be familiar with we've been
working with business throughout the
year
because whether or not we we had a free
trade agreement we were always going to
be
outside the customs union in the single
market so business knew
a significant amount of uh what was
required now that we've got the deal in
place we're working more intensively
with business
in order to make sure that everyone is
ready uh for uh the new opportunities
and indeed challenges that come
after the first of january well are you
confident that businesses are ready and
obviously they're looking at
what is now in place going through the
details i mean you
you've said in earlier on that that
perhaps you know people companies are
going to need to employ a
customs administrator i mean a business
is actually ready for this in four days
yes i think um uh the overwhelming
majority of uh businesses have been
getting ready
absolutely um and we're there to help
businesses to be ready for
uh as i say both the uh the new
opportunities but also
uh the particular new procedures that
they face as well
um and when it comes to customs uh the
sector that helps people to fill in
those customs forms
um has grown significantly um and
the last survey of how well prepared
that particular part of business was
showed that there'd been um a four-fold
increase in their ability
to be able to deal with new customs
procedures so
yes i i think business is broadly in a
good place but
inevitably with any change with any
transition
uh there are occasional bumpy moments
and and that's why government is there
to help business to be ready our
government promised
20 000 new customs officers
i mean you've had plenty time to prepare
are all of those people in place
well again there's a distinction between
the people who are
man on the border border force and we've
increased the numbers of people who work
for border force but it's also the case
that for those who are
uh at the heart of our economy for
uh those businesses that export to
europe and do beyond
uh what they tend to do is either have
in-house capacity
or they go to uh third parties to people
who are customer specialists
and those customs specialists have
indeed been increasing their numbers
and we've given some government money in
order to help them to train more people
yeah where are we though in terms of
that 20 000 figure that the government
specifically pointed out
well i i don't recall that twenty
thousand figures specifically
um what i do uh recall is uh speculation
of course over the additional number of
people
who'd be required to be customers
intermediaries and there's a range of
figures
um uh some are actually estimating that
we needed more than that
uh what we do know is that the the
industry itself has
increased in size a sort of fulfilled
increase uh according to the latest
information that we have
uh which should be sufficient to deal
with uh the the process as we
leave the customs union in the single
market in the course of the next few
days
of course one of the things that the uk
government's done in order to help
business
is to phase in our own import procedures
so
uh while it is the case that europe will
be asking certain things of
our businesses we won't be asking
anything of our own businesses
uh uh additional to what they have at
the moment uh for a good few months yet
uh what about tourists because obviously
the business is hugely important but you
know
there are more tourists uh heading out
to europe of course
and then hopefully next year that we've
seen in a while
fingers fingers crossed what are we
gonna have to do
well the the key thing there is to make
sure that your passport
is up to date um it's vitally important
to make sure that there are more than
six months on your passport
uh in order to be able to uh to travel
but you should be able to travel freely
in europe
um and uh the rules broadly are uh that
you can spend up to
90 days in europe during any 180 day
period
uh so that means that uh that people can
have
well quite leisurely holidays in europe
in an uninterrupted way but of course
as you quite rightly point out uh we
need to make sure
that we deal with the the covered
pandemic effectively
first yeah e hick the the
uh european health card i mean that's
all gone then now it's all down to our
own insurance is it
well it is important that people take
out insurance but it's also the case
that there will be
as i've mentioned before a specific
provision for people who do have very
uh serious ailments so there will be a
successor
to the e-hick card which makes sure that
those people for whom health insurance
would always be a difficult thing
can have their healthcare covered and of
course people who are currently resident
in uh the eu who are who are british and
you know there are around a million of
those
uh they have under the terms of the
withdrawal agreement access to e-hick
cards as well
what about these issues that are still
to be resolved and
there are plenty of them i mean the home
secretary saying you know the uk will be
more secure
after brexit i mean that that can't be
right
can it we we haven't sorted out security
we we haven't got
something you know to replace the
schengen information system for a
kickoff
well that's the one system that we won't
have access to we'll have access to a
variety of systems
passenger name records criminal records
and so on uh but it's also the case
we were talking earlier about the people
who man our border border force
um they will have uh new powers and uh
uh new abilities to be able to make sure
that our borders are policed
more effectively in the future uh and
the home secretary
is quite right to point out that
countries that have effective control of
their borders
are better able to protect their own
people yeah i mean
look i mean you can say that that is one
system that we haven't sorted out
yet but it is a system that british
police
access on average 1.65
million times every single day that i
mean
that that's going to live a leave a a
pretty big hole
until we get something to replace it
well there are there are other ways in
which um
uh we share information uh with our
friends in europe there are a number of
different ways and
and the uh the treaty that we've signed
the deal that we've signed
uh has detailed provisions for making
sure that we can share confidential
information
between ourselves but one of the things
about the specific
system is that in order to accept uh
that system in order to be in that
system we had to accept the fact that
the european court
could rule in our own country and one of
the points about brexit
is to be able to take back control of
our laws and indeed by taking back
control of our laws
and our borders as the home secretaries
quite rightly said we can make ourselves
safer
what's happening with the services
sector as well because the services
sector doesn't seem to be covered
by this trade agreement yet it makes up
80 percent
of our economy so it leaves it seems to
leave some very big questions for
city banks for insurance companies for
accounting firms who who don't know what
their path forward is going to be at
this stage
well it there are there are some details
on services i know i mean it's a 1246
page document and it deals with
lots of issues but it also does deal
with services
and it is clear that uh when it comes to
legal services
solicitors and barristers can uh uh
continue to uh to practice
in europe um and it also makes it clear
that there is a um a new basis on which
financial services can
operate and as the chance of the
exchequer was pointing out yesterday
uh we you know we were told years ago
that the very act
of voting for brexit would mean a
massive migration of jobs from the city
that has not happened and in fact there
are ways in which we can regulate our
financial services
in a smarter way uh in order to ensure
for example
that it's easier for companies to list
here in the uk
so uh of course we wanted to make sure
that we
support financial and other services in
the future
but it's not just about trade with the
eu it's about making sure that our
domestic regulation
is uh better designed in order to ensure
that more people
invest in this country but but that
seems to leave leave the point that
although we like to think all is done
with the eu in terms of negotiations
at least we do on this side of things
you know everyone's had enough of
talking about it there's clearly a lot
more
still to talk about i mean all these
issues your transferable professional
skills
all need to be looked at i mean there's
still quite a long way to go isn't there
well it is the case that governments are
always talking to one another to see how
they can cooperate better
uh you know that's just a factor of life
but um
the big political battles over brexit i
think are settled
now that was what um uh the prime
minister promised in the general
election last december he said we'd get
brexit done
we all remember how painful uh the
parliament
um uh that ran from 2017 to 2019 was
with all sorts of wrangles and
late night cliffhanger votes well that's
done you know the uh
boris got us out of the european union
on january
he got a great trade deal just before
christmas uh that means that we can look
forward with confidence
and yeah it's always the case that uh
the governments are making sure
that their relations with friends and
neighbors are kept in good repair
but the big arguments over brexit
they're now resolved
can i ask about fishing because
it it it was a you know the fishing
industry was actually a key factor in
pushing for brexit we know that the
the fishing industry we're very pro
brexit i mean you're from a a fishing
family we know that we
you've got a you know a vested interest
in all of this
i mean there does seem to be a huge
amount of disappointment
in the fishing sector that that you've
as they see it
sold them down the river to an extent
well i do sympathize with people in the
fishing sector um
because again life in the common
fisheries policy has been very very
difficult but what out of the common
fisheries policy
now um it is the case that under this
deal we
increase the amount of fish in our own
waters that we can catch
beforehand we could only catch about
half of the the value of the fish in our
waters now
we can go on to catch two-thirds and
indeed in five years time we'll be able
to catch
even more so of course we would like to
have been in a position where it was
only three years
before we could uh exercise uh those
additional rights
uh the eu were originally saying it
would have to be 14 years
so we got them down from uh 14 to five
and a half
um and of course at the end of those
five and a half years uh we'll have
total control
can we talk covid yeah if you would
because obviously it
it's still a huge issue the numbers are
still going up this huge amount of
concern we don't know quite what's going
to happen
in the new year in terms of further
lockdowns or extending lockdowns or
whatever
it may be what is happening with schools
it is an issue
on which the clock is very much ticking
now yes absolutely
um well the first thing to say is that
um our plan is
that primary schools will go back uh but
with secondary schools
uh it will be the case that next week
only children
in year 11 and year 13 that's those who
are doing their gcses their b techs
their their a levels
uh those will go back and also children
of key workers
um and children who are um uh you know
vulnerable and
uh who need the support and care that
school can provide
um uh other children in secondary
schools won't go back for a week
after that so just one week is is that
flexible at this stage depending on the
science
well we always keep things under review
but uh teachers and head teachers have
been working incredibly hard
um you know over the christmas period
since schools uh broke up
in order to prepare for a new testing
regime community testing
in order to make sure that the children
and all of us are safer
so we do keep things under review but
that is the plan
okay so just to clarify uh secondary
school
children unless they're in what years 11
and 13 or
years 11 213 yesterday in those years
they won't go back
years 11 and year 11 and year 13.
so uh if you're doing gcses b techs a
levels
and you're sitting them this year or
2021 i should say
then uh you are supposed to be uh
going back in the week of the fourth uh
um and of course
if your mom or dad is a key worker um or
if you're
um uh one of those vulnerable children
who who have been
uh identified and who are better
supported by being in school
then you should go back um other
children uh will be
taught remotely and will will have to
wait for another week
uh before going back how i mean
are schools prepared for that do you
think well they've been preparing very
hard
um over the course of the the holidays
um and i just think we should all be
very grateful for the fact that teachers
at the end of you know what has been a
very uh
difficult and challenging year um you
played a
brilliant role in making sure that
children could go back to school
and they've been preparing for this the
government is talking to
heads and teachers at the moment in
order to make sure that we can support
them to get children back
you're talking about the the children
going back on the fourth
who are um you know preparing for gcses
or preparing for
a levels does that mean you are
expecting exams to go ahead in the
summer
oh yes absolutely despite the fact
that's not happening in i don't think
it's scotland they're not doing exams
are they
why is it why is it the case that in
england you want those exams to go ahead
exams are critically important in making
sure
that uh that students have a chance to
show what they've learned and uh what
their skills are
um and they're an important objective
test and uh again
and you know the the scottish government
will make its own decisions uh
but uh it's it's vitally important that
children uh
have an opportunity to sit those
examinations
in order to have robust independently
scrutinized qualifications
that are a passport to a better future
um
there's a lot of hope pinned on the
oxford astrazeneca
vaccine i know you can't comment as to
whether that's going to be approved this
week because that's up to the mhra but
there's an awful lot of expectation that
it will be an awful lot of hope
hanging on that is rishi sunnah
right when he talks about you know the
possibility of lifting restrictions
in february if all this comes to pass
because
you know that that almost seems to be
ignoring the huge complications which
there are going to be
the logistical problems in getting that
rolled out
well you're absolutely right i mean i
think it's a very good explanation but
the first thing is
um we we have to wait until the
independent regulator deems whether or
not the vaccine
is ready and safe to use uh if it
is the case then the government is
prepared to uh ensure that we have
a significant increase um in the way in
which the vaccine is rolled out
and the chancellor is right as well if
we do get the authorization for that
vaccine
and the role that goes according to plan
then we will be able progressively to
lift some of the restrictions
which have made life so difficult for so
many i just wonder if it's problematic
to talk about timelines
at this stage when you know on one hand
the government talks timelines but you
also talk about the need for this
absolute flexibility which i think
people do understand
yes i think you're right i think people
do understand i i think the right
balance is the one that the chancellor
struck yesterday which is to
to outline a hopeful path to the future
uh but but to stress as you've
uh quite rightly done uh that uh it's
contingent on
uh certain things including the uh the
authorization of the vaccine
proceeding as we hope um you know people
want to have a clear sense of
of what the exit strategy is but people
are also very understanding that
events and uh circumstances which none
of us can necessarily foresee can
sometimes
delay or frustrate the progress that we
all want to make